This is Jocko podcast number 32 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
And since Jocko podcast number 31 went long with the very heavy and dark book,
we decided to end that one and not do any Q and a,
which means that today we have 100% Q and a for the troops.
And obviously this comes from the questions come from you all that are
listening.
Um,
mostly on Twitter and on Facebook is where I get these questions from.
So thanks to everyone for submitting these questions so that we can answer them
for you.
Echo.
Good evening,
good evening.
All right.
The first question I want to say I like this first question.
It's a good question.
Yup.
Echo approves of the first question.
I have most questions for sure.
Uh,
okay.
First question,
how does one who grew up in the ghetto,
quote unquote involved with gangs,
drugs,
witnessing murders and all that good stuff,
overcome that mentality where you're,
your guard is always up,
come from a family of immigrants and growing up really poor,
we had to make a lot of sacrifices and as I get older I feel that in some of
these ways,
um,
in some ways this affects my daily life.
I'm proud of my beginnings and I cherish my mistakes,
but still,
even in my senior year in college,
I feel some resentment towards these privileged kids who seem like they have it
all.
I really find it hard to get along with them because in a way I see them as weak
because they haven't suffered through hard times or have have to struggle as a
minority.
What should I do to learn to love them and respect them as equals?
Yeah,
that is,
that is a good question.
I definitely have seen a seen that seen people go through that mentality where
they're,
they're having that attitude.
And I'll tell Ya,
when I was a kid,
I actually,
I had a girlfriend when I was a good,
this,
this girl and we know in where her friend was my friend as well.
So we were all kind of friends and one of the girls,
one of the things that she said,
which I thought was brilliant and she said,
uh,
everybody has a hard luck story.
Like no matter you go and talk to somebody.
They had their struggle that they went to or went through and you know,
whether it was divorce,
whether it was abuse,
whether it was money struggles,
whether there was fighting in the house,
whether it was jail,
whether there's drugs,
whether it was alcoholic or workaholic or whatever.
Whatever situation you've been in,
everybody's got a hard luck story or something that challenged them.
And it might not be really obvious on the surface.
I mean,
you know,
for instance,
this question here,
the,
the fact,
the way that the question is phrased,
you can hear he's talking about the,
the things that we,
you know,
he said family of immigrants growing up really poor,
we had to make a lot of sacrifices,
right?
So right there,
right there,
you can see that he's got a certain amount of familial pride and he's talking
about his family as we and a group of being together.
And you know,
that might not be money that might not be expensive clothes,
but that's an incredibly powerful thing.
It's a,
you're incredibly lucky to have that.
Now you tell me who's,
who's more,
who has a tougher challenge,
the person that grows up in a tight knit family where everyone sticks together
and everyone makes sacrifices together,
or the kid who grows up,
whose dad makes a ton of money,
Dad's never home,
dad chooses,
literally chooses work over the family.
And how does that affect the kids' personality?
You know,
I mean the kids,
kids can come from any background and end up in really tough situations with
drugs,
alcohol addiction or whatever that came from really good circumstances are
really bad.
Service was,
it doesn't even matter.
You can come from both.
So.
So that's part one.
Part one is like,
you know,
you don't know what kind of struggles other people have been through.
They might have been,
they might have,
they might be at a 22 year old senior in college driving a BMW that has more
demons in their life than you do.
So it's,
it's a little bit arrogant to walk around and think that your demons or worse
than anybody else's demons,
you just don't,
you just don't know what their demons are.
Now on top of that,
if you just want to look at like the privileged,
the monetary side of it,
I promise you that despite the fact that you grew up in a ghetto and you got to,
your family had to make sacrifices.
There are people that you're the privileged to kit cause you get some kid that
grew up in South America or some kid that grew up in Africa that you know,
you think you had it tough,
they didn't have a house.
They got,
you know,
uh,
political strife in their city.
They watched their parents get killed,
whatever.
So you're a privileged person to somebody else.
So let's keep that in mind as well.
And once again,
you don't know what that looks like.
You don't know what kind of struggles people have been through.
So
let's just try and
I'll use the term judge.
Let's try and judge people not on what they are,
but on who they are as a person.
And you know,
for me,
you,
you know,
you talked about the,
the minority thing.
It to me,
I don't care about race,
color,
creed and all that stuff matters to me.
I don't care about socio economic background.
None of that stuff matters to me.
I don't judge you on that.
You know why?
Because in the military,
in the seal teams,
the,
the good seals came from every background.
Every one of those backgrounds.
The bad seals came from every one of those bad backgrounds.
There was,
there was kids that grew up rich with a silver spoon in their mouth.
They were awesome seals.
There are kids that grew up in the ghetto and their parents were gang bangers.
Awesome seals,
same as reverse is true.
There was kids that grew up with a silver spoon in their mouth and went to a
private school and they were horrible seals.
And there was kids that grew up gang bangers and they were horrible.
So,
so it doesn't matter what matters is not what you are.
It's who you are as a person.
So I,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna judge.
And in fact,
if there's,
if I was going to name some negative traits that do bother me,
it's more of them would be judging people based on stereotypes.
Be Judging people,
judging the book by its cover.
If you're doing that,
that's a negative,
you know,
that is a weakness.
So,
so just check yourself and realize that you don't know what people's backgrounds
are.
You don't know what goes on behind closed doors.
You don't know what Tufts situation people have been through and judge them not
based on that stuff.
Just judge them on who they are as a person.
Yeah.
Yeah,
fully.
And
I think this kind of helps,
you know how,
let's say like,
uh,
let's say you're in a boat,
right?
Like a rowboat and you're all trying to get upstream and you have all different
kinds of people and then you have,
you have weak or people and you have stronger people.
And the strong person
put,
whether it's by his choice or not,
he's strong.
He can,
you know,
he's been working out,
I don't know,
he's in shape.
He can roll a lot.
So he went through all this sacrifice,
but at the end he's a stronger person.
So you can look at it in a way where you now have the power.
So be responsible with your power,
like to help.
So you have to run,
it's like you have a bigger burden,
but you have to embrace that.
Not Burden,
but you have a bigger workload because you're more prepared for it in life.
And actually speaking to that.
So now that means that you have the power to to give people knowledge and
perspective on what you've been through and that's important.
Now,
there's two ways to do that.
We talk about this all the time.
If I go up to you echo and I say,
hey,
you don't know what you're doing.
Let me show you the correct way to film this.
Let me show you the correct way to use this microphone,
right?
You.
How would you feel about that?
I don't know if I would like that.
No,
no,
of course you wouldn't.
If I came up to you and said,
listen,
you don't know what it's like to struggle.
Are you going to be,
are you going to be open to hear what I'm about to say?
No,
you're not.
No one is,
no one is.
But if I said,
hey man,
it's really good to meet you.
Oh,
and then we start to develop a relationship.
But I got,
you know,
what's one thing that we got to remember is what it's like for maybe some
people,
you know,
when I was growing I had to deal with this.
Oh,
okay.
Now your mind is open to it.
You start learning,
you start growing yourself.
So by not being arrogant and by being humble and thinking that you have,
you may have been through worse things than me or whatever the case may be.
We're,
we're actually going to make each other better.
And that's the goal here.
Yeah.
So you just got to stay humble on these things and,
and it'll be,
it'll,
it'll work out better for you in the end.
It will absolutely work out better for you in the end.
Yeah.
Judge people by the content of their character,
I believe is a,
uh,
a way of putting it.
That makes a lot of sense to me.
Next question,
Jocko and echo.
How do you guys feel about the ensign,
the noise situation demoting yourself after time off the mat?
So this was a pretty interesting question.
And it's,
there's a guy named incident annoy and he's a,
he's a old school Jujitsu Guy,
old school MMA guy,
and he's a black belt in Jujitsu,
but he fought in UFC fun pride.
He was the shooto champion.
He's just to,
just to a really old school kind of Oh,
Oji from Hawaii,
from Hawaii.
And just to,
just a really well respected guy as a fighter and a guy that,
you know,
his,
he,
he kind of had that warrior ethos that people talk about,
you know,
where he would say,
look,
I'm,
I would rather die in this fight than lose.
And he meant it.
And so he's been,
but he moved to Japan,
he's of Japanese heritage and he moved to Japan a long time ago.
I mean,
I want to say 10 or maybe 15,
maybe even longer.
Yeah.
A long time ago he moved back to Japan.
He's,
he's,
uh,
you know,
that's where he's kind of built his life is in Japan.
And along the way,
I think his last fight was maybe,
maybe eight to 10 years ago,
was his last fight.
And since then,
you know,
there was the,
the horrible earthquake and the tsunami in Japan and he did work as sort of a,
as sort of a charity to raise money and help out those victims.
So that's what he's been focused on and he's been focused on I guess his family
and whatever else.
But in that time he,
he,
he strayed off the mats of justice.
He stopped the training and,
and so,
you know,
he had other things going on in his life and he stopped training.
I don't recommend anybody stopped training and um,
but for whatever reason he stopped training and he stopped training and I saw a
little interview with him as he was talking about this.
He stopped training for like 10 years,
10 years of note and he said,
no training.
He just was stopped training and now all you know,
he's,
cause he's a Jujitsu guy.
Eventually Jujitsu gets back in your brain and he started getting back on the
mats and when he got back on the mats,
he felt that he didn't deserve to be a black belt anymore.
And it wasn't just because he was,
his timing was off or he was out of condition.
He felt like Jujitsu had had changed.
And he's right in the last 10 years,
digit two.
It's changed a lot.
And you know what,
yesterday Jujitsu changed a lot.
And the day before,
I mean,
Jujitsu changes every day.
Every day it changes.
I'm,
I'm shocked.
Dean will come up with some new thing.
Dean's very,
very good at coming up with new things and he comes up with a new thing,
like something I,
neither one of us had thought of.
He probably does that once or twice a month.
He comes up with this new thing.
I might do it once every three to six months maybe.
Or I go,
okay,
I phone to something new and I'm all excited.
And Dean goes,
well,
no,
just put your hips over there.
And then I'm like,
so
it's,
it's just one of those things that it changes.
And so ensign got on the mat again and said,
oh,
I don't,
I don't think I deserve to be a black belt right now.
And so he demoted himself back to the purple belts.
And
so people said,
the question is,
how do I feel about it?
Oh,
and by the way,
since this question got asked,
he actually re promoted himself back to black belch.
Right.
So how did that go down?
That was John.
He talked to his,
his,
his instructor that gave him the black belt.
Right.
John Lewis,
from what I understand,
I didn't read it as much into that part of it.
That was mainly just reading other people's takes on it,
like their reaction.
But you didn't go to the source material almost over to the source material of
the concept more,
let's go to the source material anyway.
But he had a conversation with John Lewis and John Lewis said,
what?
What was the overall,
do you know what he said?
Well,
whatever you say,
I did go to the source material.
There you go.
And,
but I don't want to quote it exactly,
but John Louis basically said,
look,
you deserve to black belt.
Oh,
and you know what he said?
He said,
look,
someone that's a doctor that became a doctor and then that's not practicing,
but then they want to get back in the field.
They don't not become a doctor.
They just go and learn new techniques and get refreshed.
They don't have to take their doctor tag off their door and he said,
you're a doctor of Jujitsu.
You just got to get refreshed in the new techniques and get back into it.
And,
and some said,
okay,
you know,
he,
he agreed with it and he promoted himself back to black belt.
So,
you know,
again,
I think from my,
from my perspective,
um,
I say good for him.
I think both those actions I agree with.
I think it's actually pretty cool that he demoted himself and,
and said,
you know what?
I don't,
I haven't been in the game.
I got out of the game and I don't deserve to be a black belt right now.
So I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna put it on.
I'm disgracing the black belt.
But I also see the mind flip of,
Hey,
you know what?
I fought and trained for a giant portion of my life and I have innate knowledge
that got me the black belt and now I need to get back in the game.
But I'm still a black belt.
I I really respect and son,
I think he's a,
I think he's a guy with a lot of heart and pride and I respect his decision.
I don't think it's pretty simple from my perspective.
Yup.
Yeah man.
It's one of those things where when you hear someone make a good point about one
side of the whole deal,
you're like,
oh yeah,
that's true.
And then you see someone else making an,
when I saw it I was like,
Dang,
that is good.
He that is so humble and he,
and he's really keeping it real.
He's like,
I'm not a black belt.
I'm going,
I think I'm a purple belt there.
Here's where I am.
And then,
um,
Chris Helder,
who's,
he's one of the original [inaudible] in Bro,
that guy's smart.
Um,
he,
he said essentially kind of the same thing as John Lewis Ward.
It's kind of the same thing where you,
you know,
Jujitsu changes,
it doesn't be changing whether you're doing it or not and you earned it.
You're the black belt,
you know,
your instructors,
recognize you as a black belt,
you are a black belt regardless.
And just cause you jumped back on the wave of Jujitsu and maybe weren't as good
as at surfing.
You know,
you're still,
you're still that,
that black belt.
You just got it.
Like how you said,
you just got to get refreshed with all the new techniques if you want to,
you know,
be up this week.
And he said it way more eloquently than that obviously,
but men read reading now it's like,
Dang,
he's right man.
But,
but he did say that it's like,
it's kind of like false humility,
which,
um,
I did pretty much everything Chris Hunter has to say about you too,
but I couldn't really get there as far as me feeling that it was false in any
way.
No.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think so either.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't feel that,
um,
you know,
whether or not I understood exactly what,
yeah,
I guess I could see,
what are you saying
where he could come to that conclusion a little bit,
but I don't,
I don't know gree with that piece of it.
I don't because to me it's actually,
hey look guys,
I don't think there's anything false about saying,
hey,
I am not good enough to be a black belt right now.
Sort of therefore I'm putting on,
I think I'm about purple belt level.
I know what it feels like to be a black belt and I don't feel like one right
now.
Yeah,
I think that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean it does to me too.
But ultimately I think
it's,
it's however you,
and I think your instructors have a lot to do with it as well.
How however you want to see it.
You know what I mean?
I,
cause there is a lot to be said for someone who will do that because a lot of
guys,
they,
their black belt and they're gone.
You'll be like,
hey,
and some guys do it.
If they get their brown belt,
Brown belt,
I'm gone.
I'm a brown belt.
Because it does happen sometimes,
but it shouldn't happen at all.
But guys get their black belt and then stop training.
I know a few guys like that,
but you know,
so it's like,
Hey,
I got my black belt and I'm not saying they chose to do.
Yeah.
The thing that's weird about that,
the thing that makes that surprising is that it takes a lot of dedication to get
your black belt and the only way you can have that much dedication as if you
actually enjoy training Jujitsu.
And if you don't enjoy training Jujitsu,
then he'd go get your black belt.
Why would you stop training?
That doesn't make sense to me.
It's kind of like the,
the fact that people talk about going through seal training and they say,
oh,
do you really eat?
If some,
if,
if you,
they think if you,
you can make it through.
If you don't want to make it through.
If you don't truly want to make it through,
then guess what,
you're,
you're probably not going to make it through.
And it's the same thing with Jiu Jitsu.
If you don't really enjoy it,
if you're doing it just for the black belt,
it's kind of,
it's kind of hard to do it just for the black belt.
That's my point.
Just like if you're going to go through seal training just to get your seal
trident and just to claim,
Hey,
I'm a navy seal,
if that's the only reason that you're doing it,
it's gonna be hard for you to get through.
Right.
So,
so I would imagine anywhere,
I would guess that it wasn't their only reason,
but let's just say either that was a big reason to begin with or just over time
that started to be the reason,
you know,
I mean,
people can fall in and out of that mindset,
in that trap,
you know,
where it's like,
I just want that belt.
I want to walk around and be known as a black belt or whatever.
And then that mindset starts to just creep in their mind and it becomes like a
major part of their thinking.
So it's like,
Dang,
this work,
especially when frustration comes in and lights
kind of cool things about Nogi in the idea that,
and everyone gives belts now with Nogi.
I mean dean gives belts with Nogi.
I mean I support giving belts with no GI even though guide never wears a,
and he doesn't need a belt,
but you don't say,
Oh this guy's a black belt.
But one thing that is cool about Nogi and kind of,
especially during the,
uh,
during the rogue years of Nogi where it wasn't a thing yet and we were just
doing it and there were guys at the time that were only,
didn't you start off training?
Only knew Augie.
Yup.
Yeah,
there were guys that only trained Nogi.
So it was really a real thing of the belts literally didn't matter cause they
didn't exist.
And then it was just how good are you?
Where do you fall out on the totem pole of,
I can tap you,
you can't tap me,
but this guy can tap me and I,
you know what I mean?
That would,
there was something pretty cool about that because belts for me have never been
a goal or anything really to me.
To me,
I just wanted to be better
at the Jujitsu.
Yeah.
But regardless,
that is a part of it for a lot.
Yeah,
a lot for some people's thinking.
So I think with that way of thinking,
I think,
I think he can be like that.
They'll get a black belt and be like,
oh,
finally now I get to focus on my career.
And I would,
the other important thing about this is like don't stop training Jujitsu.
Like don't just stop Turkey,
man.
That's not good.
Even if you can only train a couple of times a week or once,
even if you train once a week,
man training once a week,
you know,
just to keep your head in the game,
keep your dues.
At least you can see the new moves,
you can see where things are developing.
Maybe that'll ignite your desire to get back on the map more.
But don't stop training.
You know?
And even on the days when you don't want it,
there's one day where you don't want to train Coltrane that day.
You know,
go train that day.
What it does to a big part of it,
it is,
it keeps your body in tune with the Jujitsu move from it was the general
movement.
Cause that's what one of the things that instance said where he was like,
my body wasn't moving the same,
it wasn't moving.
And there's,
it's one thing to be like,
okay,
I'm getting older,
I'm less mobile but negative.
If you did some move,
we didn't know anything about that.
But just some movement that has certain kind of movement that develops just kind
of naturally,
you know,
when you're rolling all the time and if you lose that 10 years,
I could see you lose that.
So it's like,
Dang,
my hip escape is really labored right now.
And I just,
it's hard to do when it's so easy to do normally,
you know?
So,
you know,
I can,
I can understand.
I see that,
you know.
Um,
but yeah,
that is really goes with anything.
Anything that you're doing,
like any,
you know,
where you find this also is people that are in business that whatever,
whatever level they advanced out of,
they,
they then let's say it's uh,
they move out of a technical position and they move up to a management position.
Don't just walk away completely from the technical side,
like just go,
go do it once a week.
Go get in the game.
Make sure that you still understand so that you stay so that you stay in the
game and you don't lose.
You don't wake up because you were a black belt.
That's why he got promoted above into a management position.
You are a black bottle in that technical side and they saw potential for you.
So when you walk away from it and when you move up,
don't just walk away.
Completely stay in the game.
Go.
Do you know if you're in the military just because you got promoted to whatever,
a company commander or a or a staff guy on the battalion,
they'll just say,
well,
I'm never going to go in to kill house again.
No,
no,
no.
Go on the kill house,
so even if you can only do it once every week or,
or maybe once a month,
you just get to go and keep your head in the game.
You got to do that so you stay fresh.
You stay,
like you said,
you'd keep that mental game there.
Whereas if you just walk away
and where I would have guys that were senior to me come out and go through
little blocks of training with us.
Maybe they come out and go to the kill house with us for a day.
They didn't know what they were doing.
Part of it was because they walked away for too long,
but even when they didn't know what they were doing,
you were still like,
hey man,
good for him for coming out.
You know?
It wasn't like you said,
oh,
look at him.
He doesn't know.
I don't respect him.
No,
you're actually actually the opposite is true.
You'd say,
aw man,
props,
props to the Bossier for coming out and getting after it with the boys for a
day.
He doesn't know what he's doing,
but maybe we can help them.
And if they had that mentality the whole time because it's pretty,
it's a lot easier to maintain a scale than it is to learn it.
So all you have to do,
you're a black belt man.
Get on the mat once a week,
you know,
just,
just get in there and roll.
Some people,
roll them up.
Yeah.
But um,
I back to ensign.
I dig it.
Either way I even dig it that he did it and then really took some peer review
and it was like,
I maybe didn't look at it.
This is an open minded making process.
When you went back in,
went to the stores as instructor?
Yeah,
we support down,
return back to the instructor and he was like,
hey.
And he was like,
yes,
yes sir.
You know,
that's kind of where it,
where it all came from.
Eni Eni went back to black belt.
Even that,
I can't help but respect,
you know,
pull situation it.
What if it's like a whole side note.
What if,
what if you go like,
um,
I will give you your black with Fabio,
right?
No.
Deanlets teen.
Okay.
So let's say you took 10 years off,
you came back and rule with dean.
Dean was like,
Bro,
I am your instructor.
I'm taking your belt,
I'm giving you a purple belt.
That would be awesome.
But like,
is that,
is that like,
you know,
as far as like,
can you do that or what?
Uh,
how do you feel about that?
I don't know,
but that would be very cool to see that happen.
Even just even just,
Oh,
you want to,
do you want to hear an old school story on Old School Jujitsu story?
Of course.
This is,
okay.
This is awesome.
So,
uh,
back in the day,
back in the day I was a blue belt.
Uh,
Dean was,
I think dean was a blue belt too.
He might've been a purple belt and there was another person that was a blue belt
at the time.
My wife,
your wife has a blue belts and blue belts and she was good.
She's a really good athlete.
Is that how you met your wife?
She was posed Jujitsu upon her,
wants me to write good.
So,
you know,
it was all good.
And we were training with Fabio and Fabio's,
no fraud for populous,
great instructor.
And,
and we were at the academy one day and there's a guy from out of town in right.
And he's a purple belt,
purple belt.
You know,
you figure the guy's good,
but this is back in the day too.
This isn't that in the mid nineties,
so probably like 90,
I'll see 96.
And so this guy comes in from out of town and you know,
there wasn't that many Jujitsu schools in San Diego.
There was like to write and it was that,
it was Fabio.
There was Rodrigo,
I think that was it at the time.
So anyways,
this guy comes in,
he's kind of a,
he's probably 35 years old,
probably 150 pounds,
purple belt.
So,
you know,
we're rolling and we're a little bit like,
okay,
the guys are pro vote.
Um,
but there's that attitude of the guys know,
the guy knows what he's doing.
So I didn't roll them,
but I'm watching him.
I'm rolling with Dean,
we're doing our thing and it's kind of the open mat period.
And,
and Fabio has enrolled with my wife and so my wife's,
you know,
she's good.
She's,
but she's,
uh,
the rolling and he gets her in a choke.
He gets her in a rear naked choke and she buries her chin,
like a white belt of like a,
like a defense,
you know,
I'm going very much answer.
He's not gonna choke me.
He chokes her face,
like I'm talking legit gets after it on her face and she starts crying and a
little bit of blood all day and she had so,
so I'm just like,
and so I hear her scream or whatever.
And then I,
and then,
uh,
you know,
she gets up and he lets go and he's kind of like,
oh,
sorry,
uh,
blah,
blah blah.
And Fabio,
it looks at me,
he goes,
and the guy didn't know this.
My wife,
Fabio goes,
was Jocko,
you row with him now.
And I go,
okay.
So I even,
I,
I was like,
okay,
I'm going to smash him.
But I didn't intentionally like,
oh,
assault him.
I just smashed him.
I mean I'm,
I crushed him and submitted him,
but I didn't like break his arm and,
but I smashed him and I was doing a lot of neon stomach at the time,
so I was just driving.
No dude,
it was like an early version of the park bench.
Sean's Dude I had who did the knee in his neck and we're smashing him and um,
and then I get done and I wore them out pretty good.
And Fabi was like,
now I will roll with you.
And Fabio tore him up and uh,
was like cracking armbars on him and choking him and smashing him.
And then the guys like the guys like broken down and Fabio is,
Fabio said,
you're not a purple belt.
And I can't remember if he took his purple belt,
but he kicked him out and he said,
don't ever come back here and you're not a purple belt.
And He,
I think he took his purple belt and said,
you're not a purple boat.
No.
You know,
he,
he's,
he also said,
I have one thing I remember him saying,
he was like,
this girl's been training here for two and a half years.
She's never been hurt.
She's never had a problem.
You come in here and hurt this girl,
you're not a purple belt.
You don't know what you're doing.
Give me your purple belt.
Yeah.
So that was a cool demotion.
Courtesy of Fabio Santos,
the old school Jujitsu.
Right.
They're so dang.
Yeah.
That's um,
yeah,
different situation though.
Yes,
it is a different situation,
but I think,
I don't know,
maybe we need to see more demotions in Jiu Jitsu.
That's a possibility.
Maybe I needed to get started on that.
Demote myself right now.
So,
all right,
that's awesome.
But yeah.
Yeah.
Man.
Old School Jujitsu.
Fabio.
But it's kind of interesting though,
right?
Cause it kind of falls the thing in the same way,
like in the same line is is that acceptable for a professor to demote their
student if they lost a step or once you earn that,
that black belt or the whatever the belt is once you earn it it's like you paid
those dues.
Yeah,
that's a tough one.
It's
interesting.
I,
I dunno,
I think,
I think I might be wrong in terms of the way view it,
but I think d motion is,
is kind of cool.
I think,
I think more demotions need to happen.
Like,
oh you haven't been coming to the gym for two years.
Cool.
Give gimme your brown belt.
You know what I mean?
Hey man,
sorry.
You know,
no one's ever going to come to my academy.
No,
I wouldn't say that.
That could be the case.
If the re like if you're,
if you're this highly competitive uh,
philosophy type team where you,
if you go out in autonomy,
you have to represent and that was the culture.
Real rigid like that then.
Yeah.
But you know Jiu Jitsu for life,
you know,
you can take 10 years off Jujitsu,
it's kind of part of you or whatever.
You were awarded this belt through your time efforts and stuff like that.
Then it's like now I've got to worry about all my time and effort that would
scare people off to go back cause I don't want to get demoted.
Yeah,
exactly.
We got to do to earn it back.
But like I said,
if there was a job that you had to do,
basically it's like if you have a job to do as a brown belt,
you have to represent you.
You know,
like in a,
in a company or something,
you can't be the director of sales,
get that job and then now your performance sucks.
You know,
you can't do remit because you have a job to do.
But like I said,
you just is not really a job where,
I don't know.
I mean when you're a brown belt in their school,
you have to go and help train the other people.
That's part of your job,
right?
Yeah.
You have to show up and train with me,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
If you're violating some,
you know,
some ethics or something like that,
then I mean even then you don't really take away the belt.
You'd take away their whole get outta here.
You know that.
But I think so.
So the bottom line is,
although I think demotions would be cool,
I don't think it's probably going to happen.
And I think that the,
I think that's tradition because although I do believe,
I think emotions are good idea.
I also do like some of the traditional aspects of Jujitsu and one of the
traditional aspects is when you get a belt to belt,
yeah you did it,
you put it all that time,
all that effort,
all that knowledge,
you know,
alright you get to keep your belt people barely.
But here's the,
here's the thing,
I think that's,
that's interesting about those funny is at the gym I will shout out things like,
like take that guys cause brown belt,
purple belt is really doing good against the brown belt.
I'll be like,
take his brown belt from him,
do it,
or kind of an instigator.
I liked that.
I liked it.
That's part of our fun culture where you can say,
or if you roll with it,
let's say like,
oh,
I'll do this with like my friends or whatever.
If they're a brown belt in a in,
you know,
same belt as you,
and you get them and you get them like kind of easy or with a new move or
something that's real flashy or something,
you take their belt and say like,
you don't deserve that right now.
We're going to roll your doorbell.
You know what I mean?
But I think that that's kind of what's in our minds anyway.
So let's say a guy rolls in and he's a brown belt and he's getting smashed or
whatever by like purple belts.
One of the best things about Jujitsu is that the belt,
it doesn't really mean anything because you,
if you're a black belt and you come in here getting smashed by blue belts,
no one's sitting there thinking,
wow,
he's a black belt.
They're thinking,
no,
there's something wrong with them.
Yep,
exactly.
No,
no black button here.
So that's,
that's one of the best things about Jujitsu is the truth is on the mat.
So I guess it doesn't,
you don't need to get demoted.
Your mere existence is it
motion if you're not,
if you're not training,
like he goes back to what I was saying where you put in all that time because
it's really,
the belt is based on specific things and those things,
if you've done those things,
you've taken the time is one of them.
The knowledge,
the,
you know,
understanding of all this.
So I'll basically all,
all that the belt is based on,
that doesn't really go away.
You put in that time,
you have that knowledge,
you know.
All right.
I think echo scared.
I'm going to take his belt away
from,
maybe I'll take your belt through it.
Bring it,
there's going to be about a 45 second break in the podcast right now.
Anyway.
All right,
next question.
Dead Horse.
Go Jocko.
What do I say to someone I've trained and later claims this person claims that a
certain thing was not covered in the training.
Uh,
in addition to the question says,
obviously excuses,
obviously excuses.
So this is,
uh,
this is a really pretty common question of how do you handle these situations.
And I've actually been lucky enough in my life to run a lot of training into a
lot of different situations,
mostly in the military.
And I've absolutely had this happen.
And there's one thing that I do when this happens,
and you can probably guess what it is,
I take ownership of it.
So check it out.
If somebody comes to me and says,
Oh,
you were supposed to train us on x and you didn't,
and I know that I did,
and it was in the curriculum and we covered it.
And I say,
I don't say no.
I trained you in into here it is.
No,
I say,
okay,
let's get it trained.
Then what do I gotta do?
Lay.
Here it is.
Let me Redo the curriculum.
Let me show it to you again because here's the thing,
as a trainer,
it's not just your job.
This is what I used to tell my guys when I ran training.
The guys that were the instructor cadre,
I'd say,
listen to it isn't your job just to run the training,
just to provide the training.
It is your job to ensure that the training is absorbed.
That's the difference.
That's a big difference between philosophies of training.
I,
my goal when I'm training someone is to make sure that the training is absorbed
into the mind.
Otherwise go watch a youtube video because a youtube video,
you can see the same instruction.
Yeah,
but no,
I need to seek you out and say,
okay,
where?
Where did you miss it?
Where did and also where did I fail in my training?
If I covered it,
why don't you remember it?
That means I didn't cover well enough or I didn't teach it well enough and I
think that you,
you then you retrain them.
You get them up to speed.
At some point they're going to realize that you did train them.
I mean,
if they truly forgot or even if they didn't forget,
but they're just placing the blame on you,
they're going to realize that you know,
they're gonna know that you know,
that you train them when they,
when you reflect the same information
and do it again.
So I think it's pretty simple answer.
Uh,
when someone is saying you haven't trained them,
take responsibility for it,
take ownership for it and say,
okay,
look,
let me get you trained on it.
My,
my apologies.
I'm here to train you.
Let me make sure that I train you and make sure that you absorb it.
Let's go.
I think that your way of training should be
done or performed with kids as well.
Like parents with their kids,
you know how,
cause you know how the kid,
the kid's misbehaving and the variants,
like I dunno why he does that.
I told him not to pitch a fit.
Oh yeah,
I know you've probably told them or you went through the motions of telling them
or whatever.
But man,
you gotta you gotta train them and make sure that it's absorbed.
You know?
Absolutely.
Still.
And I always kind of think of it this way,
not kind of,
I really think of it this way where if your kid is misbehaving,
it's something you did or didn't do,
of course.
So you can't really sit there and be like,
oh,
blaming the kid for misbehaving or whatever.
Or you know,
you're,
you're right.
I wonder,
isn't it weird that you can have families where one kid can go to go to high
school and do well and do great on their sats and get to a great college and go
to and go be a doctor and the other kid can become a heroin addict.
Yup.
Isn't that strange?
It's interesting,
but I,
and I think long time ago I would talk to you about this like long time and how
do we blame the parents and well that's the thing.
That's the,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm not saying blame the parents.
I'm not saying that cause because that would,
if you're blaming them,
nothing thing.
It's so easy.
Why didn't you do that?
I blame you.
You don't kind of thing.
It's not easy.
Probably.
There's so many different dynamics to every kid's experience.
So you know how,
and this is how the conversation kind of,
if I remember correctly,
kind of started when you were like,
Hey,
I have,
you know,
four kids or whatever,
and they're just different.
They are all,
and then I said,
and this was before I had kids by the way.
So you weren't really feeling what,
Oh,
the day you didn't,
you don't really care about that.
Well,
not to say you did anyway.
I said,
um,
okay.
Yeah,
it's kind of complicated.
So Oh,
kids are different.
Yeah.
But they're not just different,
like that's not it.
That's not nature.
Annulation yes,
yes,
yes.
Fully.
So consider every kid starting point is different.
So you can't expect everyone,
every kids ending point to be the same.
Even though they go through the same experience.
Just being the second born,
you're starting out as a completely different human being.
Just being two years,
one year,
five years younger than your older brother is.
Minor variables end up creating some major differences.
Yes,
of course.
At,
at certain points in development,
they're going to have kind of the same needs but in a different environment.
So the way that you fulfilled
those same needs with the first kid are going to look different as far as them
being translated with the second kid and the third kid and the Fort,
you know,
however many kids you have,
that's going to be making slight adaptations to what you did to the second kid.
And the first,
and to keep a handle of all those dynamics is it's hard.
So that's why it's only that it's not an exact science.
Yeah.
And,
and the way kids react way people,
it's not just,
we're not just talking about kids here,
we're talking about people you know,
because you get different people that you hire at different times or different
people that join tunes at different times and they have a different attitude.
So yeah,
you got to adjust.
But the,
the bottom line is,
the thing that remains constant through all this is that if you're trying to
impart knowledge on people,
you need to take responsibility,
not just for showing them the knowledge,
but to making sure that they absorb the knowledge.
And the primary methodology of doing that is by explaining to people why they're
doing what they're doing and why you're telling them this and why this occurs.
So if,
like you said,
you tell your kid don't have a temper tantrum and then you never explained to
them,
here's why you don't want to have a temper tantrum.
But when you're doing this,
you could hurt yourself.
You could hurt other people.
You're going to do things that regret.
You can invite,
break something in the house.
I can't control you.
I can't bring you anywhere.
If you're going to act like this,
that means we can't go out and have fun.
So you've got to explain why.
And once you explain why,
then people have a better chance of absorbing the information.
But yes,
you as a trainer,
parent leader,
teacher has a responsibility not just to impart knowledge,
but to ensure that the knowledge is absorbed.
Yeah.
Rant,
complete.
And of course,
like I said,
it's for parenting.
It's not just that easy.
You know,
parenting is very difficult leadership situations.
So it's really a lot like Plinko considered,
you know what I mean?
He started at a different point and he's very well,
but yeah,
there you go.
So next question
Jocko.
Yes.
In the seal teams you lead all male teams.
Any leadership difference?
In business?
We're in the business world with mixed agenda or female teams.
So first of all,
in the military I did work with women.
There's,
there's no women in the seal teams,
but there's women that are an intel.
There's women that are in logistics,
there's women in the,
in the,
some of the logistics support units that go out in the field sometimes.
So definitely worked with women in the military and in the civilian sector.
With the,
with echelon front,
I've worked with all kinds of women,
all kinds of women in every level,
from CEO's on down to frontline troopers.
And here's the deal.
For me,
it's no factor,
no factor to me.
What's a factor to me is can they do their job?
Do they have an open mind?
Are they humble?
Do they treat people with respect?
Those are the kinds of things that I'm judging.
It's like what we talked about earlier.
I'm judging,
but I'm not judging based on what they are.
I'm judging on who they are and who they are as a person.
So that's,
I see no real difference.
The leadership,
the way that you lead doesn't change in my opinion from the,
from the women I've seen in leadership positions to the men I've seen in
leadership positions.
The,
the,
the way they lead is successful because the way they lead,
not because they're male or female.
And you know,
some of the stereotypes that that you might see out there.
Um,
like he,
like,
like for instance,
men are tougher than women or,
or men or women are more emotional than men.
That's just garbage.
Jane,
if you see,
I've seen,
at least when you get to a leadership position,
I've definitely seen women that were way tougher than than guys were in terms
of,
hey,
we've got to make this move for the company.
Here's what I'm going to do.
Boom.
They execute it.
And I've seen men that were way too emotional attached to this scenario and
ruined it because they're just way more emotional than the stereotypical woman
might be.
So that's why I don't think you can trust them.
I look at a person,
not whether they're a man or a woman,
I'm looking at there the content of their character for the second time.
I'll say that today.
Mlk.
Um,
and now when we start talking about combat,
um,
there's some physical differences that make,
that make a definite impact.
And I talked about on the Tim Kennedy,
if you want to hear ever hear me talk about that because yeah,
when you get into some physical things,
men are stronger than women.
And so there's a,
there's some physical limitations there.
But in terms of leadership capabilities in the,
in the civilian sector,
there's,
yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not worried about men and women do.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are there some nuances there?
There are.
There are new apps for instance,
who were like,
one you'll hear is,
um,
I'll get asked,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a female and I'm in charge of these guys.
Uh,
you know,
how should I act or what should I do?
Cause they,
they might not like working for a,
for a,
for a girl.
Right.
And I say they fired that guy.
Probably wouldn't like working for a guy either or a free younger guy or for a
guy that got moved from another department.
There's,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
So what are you going to do?
I always say,
be humble.
Listen to what they have to say.
Keep an open mind.
That's what you're gonna do regardless.
Male,
female,
whatever.
It just older,
younger,
doesn't matter.
You want it.
The being a good leader,
the principles don't change.
That's all there is to it.
Yeah.
Cause as an insecure guy giving,
getting led or,
or,
uh,
a girl calling shots or whatever will affect them.
[inaudible] but like how you said,
if they,
if their leadership principles are sound,
yeah.
It doesn't matter.
They're making the right call.
It's going to be obvious that,
that like that guy's messing up or you know,
like he's,
he's,
um,
acting out of insecurity or not acting out of insecurity.
It's gonna be obvious the leadership part.
As long as that sound,
you're going to have success.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
that's no factor to me.
Yeah.
Next question.
Maybe I should bring some of the female leaders that I've worked with on the
podcast.
You know,
the thing,
the problem with that is there are no different than the male leaders I've
worked with.
So I'm sure that there's some,
some women would have listened this,
Nicole.
Oh,
you don't know how hard it is when acts or you don't know.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like they'll good female leaders I've worked with have been like,
oh yeah,
that can be sometimes a problem because I'm a woman in,
here's what I do to negate it,
right?
Because I guess what?
The next day I'll be working with a different client and the,
it's a man and he goes,
well,
you know,
I have to do with x and this is how I mitigate it,
so everyone's dealing with x,
right?
Everyone's got some factor that they're trying to overcome and it's just a good
leader will find a way around that factor or find a way to mitigate that factor
and a bad leader won't and we'll then use that factor as an excuse,
right.
Rather than just as an advantage.
You know,
there's a huge difference between taking ownership of these problems and saying,
oh,
you don't want to,
here's the issue.
Okay,
I'm going to own that.
I'm going to take care of it,
and we can find a way around it.
Instead of saying,
Oh,
I'm younger,
I'm older,
I'm a woman,
I'm a man trying to lead these words.
It's just like,
no,
you're a human leading another human being.
And so step up and lead,
figure out what the issues are and overcome them.
Yeah.
Jocko,
I've taken a lot of inspiration from your philosophy of good,
how do you apply this without succumbing to Pollyanna Chism did I say that
right?
So
pollyannish is a,
is a,
is a term and it actually comes from a,
from a novel from the early 19 hundreds,
but it,
uh,
the name of the novels Pollyanna in anyways Pollyanna and the book has this
really super positive attitude and it's almost so positive that it overwhelms
and it kinda changes people's attitudes in the town.
But there's a pejorative meaning of this word,
which is what this guy's asking about.
And it is,
that is when,
when someone is so positive that they,
that they forget about reality of a situation,
you know?
And so that's,
that's,
that can be absolutely problematic.
And that is not what I'm telling anybody to do.
In fact,
the,
let's,
let's not mistake the,
the good philosophy as one that negates reality,
that totally off.
That's not what I'm telling you wanted to do.
In fact,
the very first thing you have to do is accept reality.
That's the first thing you gotta do.
You gotta look at what's happening.
You've got to assess it,
assess the reality of it,
and then you say,
okay,
good.
Now instead of dwelling on the negatives and what's going to go bad and what's
wrong,
you deal with them,
but then you look at,
okay,
now what are we going to do positive out of this?
What good's going to come out of this?
And that's,
that's all it is.
It's definitely not denying or being delusional about the situation by any
stretch,
but it is also not being,
woe is me and all of this happened and now,
oh my gosh,
everything's going horrible.
I'm doomed.
No,
that's,
that's not what I'm talking about.
Obviously I'm not talking about that and it's also not like it's okay,
everything's wonderful.
No,
that's why the term is good and not wonderful,
right?
I'm not saying everything's wonderful,
but good.
Okay,
now what are we going to find out of this?
What are we going to figure it out?
But this is what are we going to make happen now because I'm going to deal with
reality.
I'm going to accept reality,
I'm going to accept reality.
Yeah.
Then there's some people that you know,
like the,
the self help gurus that are like,
no,
I'm just not going to accept that.
It's not going to happen.
I need to grow in reality.
I'm going to be so positive that I'm going to get that million dollars tomorrow.
No,
no,
actually you're not going to get that million dollars tomorrow.
You're going to have to work.
You're gonna have to work for a long time.
You're going to have to work hard.
You're gonna have to stay focused on your goals,
and then you get your million dollars.
Good seal strong.
Urf.
Yes.
So that's it.
Deal with reality except reality than find the good in it and move forward.
That's a cool video by the way,
that you,
that you mean
you liked that video?
I do.
I think is that you fishing for a compliment?
That video is a,
I think you,
I spend a lot of people watch that video.
Yeah.
It's interesting too because you made that video and you made another video.
Uh,
where does discipline come from?
And I actually personally,
I like to,
where does this passion come from?
Video better.
But the good video,
it just strikes a chord with people.
The APP.
Cause I think,
I think because it applies so universally to negativity in the world,
like okay,
the up,
these bad things are happening right now.
In fact,
I get so much feedback of people that literally say,
you know,
thank you for introducing me to that idea,
that philosophy because it's changed my attitude and now when things go wrong I
say good,
now what am I going to do about it?
Right.
So I think that's why that video is,
is,
is quite popular.
That and the unbelievable editing that was done when it was put together.
Yeah.
And it,
it does seem like a real,
um,
like personal,
like deeply personal thing.
Like,
cause it's like,
it's more,
um,
it's not sensationalization
of it.
It's just,
it's real kind of kind of dark,
whatever.
And like how you said,
like the negative part of it,
it's like I said this last time or it's a painkiller.
So then a Multivitamin,
you know,
what do you mean by that?
Meaning of heard you say that before.
Meaning like if you have a problem,
you just in nature,
when you,
when you're going along,
what are your brain is,
is evolved to recognize problems.
And if something isn't a problem,
it'll start to filter that out.
That's just how you bring it.
Okay.
So in life,
when you have problems,
that's what's always on the radar.
Now you have this little personal like tool that's talking to you of how to deal
with those problems.
Nice.
You know what I mean?
So,
um,
so it's,
it's kind of that like the discipline,
where does discipline come from?
It's Kinda,
that's more starts to go into the multivitamin thing where it's like,
this is not a big problem.
I'm going to try to recognize it as a problem.
I need more discipline,
you know?
But it's not really this huge problem,
but it does help,
you know,
kind of thing.
So it's like a multivitamin.
Interesting.
Um,
but I like the discipline one as well.
Okay,
next question,
coach Jocko,
what are your thoughts?
I wonder who does that mean?
Did you,
did you guy wrote that?
Uh,
pink.
So must be,
it must,
must be,
but is it someone from like the Jimmy Think,
I dunno to address me as coach and first of all,
if you come to my gym,
you don't have to call me coach.
Maybe that's why he's doing,
maybe he just knows him a black belt and thinks I should be called coachable.
Yeah.
Or it could be like,
when I'm like chief,
you know,
hey,
what's up chief?
What's up coach?
I've heard coach.
In fact,
I don't mind coach in that regard,
but only a brown belt.
How can you like coach?
Nah,
but in life,
you know what?
I remember when I said long time ago where I was like,
no,
I don't like,
I don't mind.
Oh,
you don't like boss?
Yes.
Or Dude,
when a girl says,
dude,
but I actually,
I used to joke and I'd say,
look guys,
if you don't feel comfortable calling me Sensei or instructor or coach,
you can just call me master either one.
But the reality is just call me Jocko.
Yeah,
I heard someone call you coach,
um,
is,
you know,
I'll certain guys they liked that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Correct.
People I don't say,
don't call me coach,
you know,
I just,
I'm okay.
I don't care what people call me to be honest with,
with you.
Well,
oh,
but yeah.
Yeah.
The guy called,
he was weird.
Was like he kept calling.
No,
there's,
there's a,
there's definitely a handful of people that call me coach.
Yeah.
Maybe they don't know what my name is.
All right.
So go back to the question.
Click coach,
uh,
coach Jocko.
What are your thoughts on dealing with old age when getting physically stronger
and faster ain't going to happen?
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know the answer to that question
about age because it's not happening to me.
I'm not getting any older.
I mean,
when is it that it that it ain't going to happen anymore?
I don't know because I'm continuing to train on
continuing to do what I do.
I've had people tell me that wall when you hit 30 and then I had to,
when you hit 35 and then you get 40 now it's when you hit 45 now I'm here and
when it's 50 so,
um,
yeah,
I don't know.
I just know that I'm just going to keep getting after it.
I'm going to keep getting stronger.
I'm gonna keep getting faster and we keep getting better.
And if I can't beat my record,
well then how close can I get?
How close can I get to the record?
And I think I've talked about this before,
is like I always think about decay and how if you don't fight the K it starts to
just,
you won't notice it.
It's slow and it's,
it's,
it's like moving like the hour hand.
Like you don't see it happening.
And I think that's why I think this is why a lot of aging happens because people
don't notice that it's happening.
So don't pay attention to it.
So what happens is they don't hold the line,
hold the line.
And like I track my workouts,
I'm not OCD about it.
I'm not like a psycho.
Like,
you know,
hey,
I did it in 14 minutes and 32 seconds and then,
and then I refer back to it.
No,
but I know the general trends and I know where the numbers are and I know where
they should be and I know that I need to always keep those in mind.
You know,
how many pull ups can I do?
How much can I squat,
how much,
you know,
just those,
just those numbers.
So you keep them in line.
And I think what that does the,
I do that so I can't hold the line because like I said,
I think age sneaks,
I don't think age just salts.
You,
I think it sneaks up on you and the way it sneaks up on you is a missed rep
there and uh,
and a slower lap over here and a missed workout over there and you just boom.
There's just that little age is chipping away at you.
It's just chipping away.
It doesn't,
it actually doesn't want you to notice.
He doesn't want,
that's why it doesn't hit you all at once.
It doesn't just wants to chip away and then you fast forward 15 years and you're
not the same guy you were because those chips I've taken taken all your
strength,
the way they've taken your flexibility way.
They've,
they've,
they've done a done work on you.
So that's why I,
like I said,
I don't know what am I going to be able to hold the same records when I'm 59 and
when we got some older guys like you know Gordon Gordon's 54 and I trained with
Gordon.
Yeah.
I tried with Gordon,
I mean Gordon's legit blackbelt and,
and he's not just a legit back but with knowledge like you can train with him
and he trains hard.
So I'm just very,
I try and stay self aware and I think I try and prevent the cutting of corners
and I try and maintain the daily discipline in all things.
That's what I try and do because when you start cutting those corners is when I
think it adds up over 15 years and you wake up and you're not the person that
you remembered that you were and you're not the person you want to be.
So you to maintain and hold that line as long as you can.
And I'm always actually trying to do new things too,
like trying to figure out something else that's new.
Some other technique I've never done before.
Some exercise,
I haven't got to buy some weird piece of exercise gear because I'll see
something cool on the interwebs and I'll go,
Dang,
I can't do that.
How's that 14 year old girl doing that?
I want to learn how to do that.
And so that's,
that's,
I think you've got to fight it.
Yeah.
And that,
that,
that's a good analogy.
The hour hand,
where are you can't,
you can't see it when you watch it all day.
You can't see a nope,
but look away for one second.
Not One second,
but you know,
look away for a little while.
You look back and boom that things snuck right up on you and,
and that's,
I mean that's how you really slick.
That's how little assault you as far as age and decay goes where if you,
if you stop for awhile and you try to come back,
if you stop for 10 years and you try to come back,
that hour hand moved a lot and moved a lot.
The MN.
So if you weren't fighting it,
yeah cause you can hold that our line,
I mean you can hold it up.
Maybe you can't stop.
It could slow that song.
Just got to keep your eye right on the back.
It's not moving it off.
And sure.
You know,
like I said,
when you're 90 and you've been looking at that hour hand since you were 25 then
yeah,
you're going to be like,
oh I remember back when I was 25 is way over here and I'm way over here fitness
wise or whatever.
Or I can squat less or whatever.
Of course,
you know that's the
inevitability.
But just like how you said,
yeah,
if you,
you just stay on that,
that discipline in all things and you're going to hold that,
you're going to hold it good.
Do not go gentle into that good light.
Yeah.
Rage,
rage against the dying of the light.
And with that,
the,
you know,
this kind of balance to all things don't get crazy.
You know how guys will just be red lining their workout cause they're trying to
maintain that match.
You can't,
you gotta be careful about that.
Yeah man.
Cause it's just like a race car.
You can't keep the race car in the red.
You got to,
you got to bring it back to the shop.
Sometimes I get a little tuneup.
Yup.
They've got to be part of the routine.
Yeah.
And I can only,
I'm,
you know,
I'm pretty good.
That's another thing is the more you work out,
the more you train,
the more the,
the,
the better.
You know,
your own body.
Yeah.
And you know,
you walk up to the gym sometimes.
Like what was it yesterday?
Yeah.
Yesterday,
man,
I felt like Superman.
Like I was just super strong.
I was doing one of my work,
I was strong,
I was just technical.
I just felt great,
you know?
And I would say there's some days that I go in the gym and I'm like,
what?
You know,
I got to stretch.
I got to like take an easy day.
And,
and then there's some days where I say I gotta take an easy day,
but anyways,
I'm just going to get crushed and I'm just going to crush this thing.
But,
and part of that,
again,
because I see that you got to make sure that you're not cutting corners.
Got To make sure that you're not taking your eye off the hour and sometimes you
don't let nothing get up,
get one up on you cause you're lazy.
Right.
So that's why going,
this is sometimes a lot of workouts I have,
you know,
I have some days,
some days where I feel like Superman,
I have some days where I feel like,
uh,
like horrible.
And I have a lot of more like Lois Lois Lois Lane or something.
Yeah.
Some days where I feel like I'm just going through the motions,
but going through the motions is okay.
Yeah.
It's okay to go in there and go through the motions.
It's okay to go in there and not break any records going in there and going
through the motions is generally a thousand times better than not doing
anything.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that,
that's actually,
I mean,
red lining it all the time is,
uh,
is the easy way to get knocked right out of the game.
Yeah.
Well you'll get injured after awhile.
That's what I mean,
especially when you start getting older.
You know,
maybe
I need to say that.
All right,
next question.
What do you got?
What are your favorite podcasts in a y Hashtag name dropping is.
Okay.
Um,
so anybody that listens to me,
there's,
there's a couple of podcasts that I listen to and they're really obvious and
they're like the big,
the big podcasts
you got.
Well,
Tim Ferris,
boom,
right?
You got Joe Rogan,
boom.
You've got Sam Harris,
Um,
and you've got hardcore history with Dan Carlin and he's got another one that's
called the common sense.
And I,
the those,
those all those,
uh,
are really,
really good podcasts.
And,
um,
I'm,
I've been listening to a podcast for many,
many years now,
uh,
before listening to podcasts.
It was cool.
I was listening to a podcast.
I actually grew up listening to radio shows.
I've talked about that before,
but I,
I have and I forget,
I actually,
I cannot remember how I got into podcasts.
I do not remember how I got into podcasts.
Um,
but anyways,
whenever I got into podcasts,
those are the kind of the ones that I listened to you.
And I've,
I sample a lot of other podcasts and sometimes I'll search for certain topics
and I'll just listen to a random podcast.
Um,
one of the,
but there's one more.
The only one that I have that's like not on the main,
uh,
sites,
hey look,
in people's view is a podcast called martyrmade and it's by a guy named Daryl
Cooper.
And I can't recommend that,
that podcast strongly enough.
It's outstanding.
It is an outstanding podcast.
And Daryl Cooper,
I don't even know,
like ease,
just this underground guy.
I think he's a,
I think he was in the navy,
but he does not.
He's not anymore.
He's,
he doesn't do it.
It's not like a profession for him,
but he should be.
He should be.
It's a great podcast.
So check out Marger made.
It's also a,
he's on Twitter under martyrmade,
his,
his call sign,
but he's got like 142 followers,
like no one knows about it.
No one knows about them.
And actually,
you know what,
it was somebody on Twitter and I don't forget who it was.
It was somebody on Twitter that told me about Margaret made and just said,
check it out.
And when people tell me to check them out,
man,
I check it out.
And it's,
as soon as you opened it,
you know,
you're gonna,
you're gonna realize why it's so good.
Um,
really detailed,
really very good historical research and it's a great podcast.
And those are the,
and,
and you know what?
I'm a really picky podcast guy too.
Like,
I'm really,
I need somebody to get,
I need,
somebody needs to bring it on their podcast for me to like it.
I try all,
I try new podcasts all the time and I don't get a lot of repeat customers
myself.
Like I don't repeat a lot.
Um,
because
I just,
yeah,
it needs to be really,
really solid.
That's for me to list for me,
do for me to invest hours worth of my time.
That's,
that's gotta be a heavy investment and it's gotta be something that's worth my
while.
And that's why those that I mentioned,
let me grab,
I'm just seeing if on my phone,
if there's any others that I might've missed,
but I don't think as far as like massively good ones that I can recommend across
the board.
Um,
those are them.
And you know,
there's other ones that I'll occasionally listen to,
but,
um,
and those are all kind of like the Po,
the popular ones that come out.
Danko Jones has got a good podcast and he interviews talks about rock and roll.
I dig that one only because I really dig Danko Jones.
Uh,
the band as well.
The martyr made one.
Yes.
What's kind of the format with felony?
It's sip.
No,
it's similar to a hardcore history.
It's a him,
it's Daryl Cooper just talking about,
and that one,
I think it's going to be his,
it's about the Israeli Palestinian conflict that goes all the way back to the
beginning and talks to you about what it is and what it's about.
And it's,
it's really good.
So those are the main podcast that I listened to.
Um,
again,
you've got to,
and it's just a big investment of time.
And especially cause I don't have a commute so I don't drive anywhere.
So,
and I'm in,
in,
I can't,
I can't do anything mentally and do a podcast at the same at the time and
listened to a podcast so I can't read and listened to a podcast doesn't work.
The only thing I can do is drive and do yard work.
Like anything that's like actually when I have a big project to do at the house,
I love it cause I can get it all caught up on podcasts and whatever.
So,
but yeah,
you know
what that is,
you know girls can do that.
You know that I was not aware of that.
Yeah.
So this is all it is.
That's how it works.
Girls can they sit?
They,
I don't want to be dismissive and call it multitasking because it's,
it goes,
it's more deep than multitask.
Girls can do things that require re like attention.
They can do more than one.
Um,
and then you guys can't,
I would be impressed by a girl that could listen to a legit podcast and read a
book and get like the full value out of both of them.
So how girl's brains are wired?
They can do that a lot better than guys and guys.
But how's this though?
This is kind of interesting and I used to do this all the time to mess with
girls.
Guys have a different spacial awareness and girls do.
So one of the tests that was done,
it was like,
ah,
I want to say 16,
I don't know the numbers,
but it was a classroom just full of guys,
classroom full of girls.
Then they'd run all these tests,
different tests.
But one of them was you have to draw a bicycle.
That's it.
So a bicycle is this kind of in a way,
kind of in this unique thing when you draw it,
because you have to know where this goes because that affects,
you know,
the pedals got to affect the chain that affects it's s it proved a or indicated
spacial awareness,
right?
So of the experiment,
all the guys could do it.
You don't have to be an artist.
Some bikes didn't look amazing,
but they were working.
You don't have to be an artist.
And it doesn't matter if you're a bike rider too.
So all the guys could do it.
You know how many of the girls could do it?
No.
None.
Really none.
Yes.
So,
and I've done this experiment and if you're going to do this experiment,
do it correctly.
Don't be like,
Hey,
here's a bike.
Copy this,
but don't,
don't cheat on it.
Really.
If you really want to get to the bottom,
tell ASCA girl,
any girl,
woman,
no matter what age,
draw a working bicycle,
they can't do it.
I have yet to come across the girl that can do it tonight as a and as a guy,
it's pretty,
most guys will do it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's weird.
But anyway,
it's just,
just how the brains are different.
Cause other fun stuff too.
For me it is very difficult to actually engage in a book and reading,
um,
or writing while I'm listening to someone else talk about something
intellectual.
It's very challenging for me.
Yeah.
Fully.
That's it.
To get the full value.
I mean I can do it but at the both efforts are half ass and I don't get anything
out of him.
Well yeah.
Did you,
is there any podcasts you listen to?
God I mentioned strangely it's the same thing except for the martyr made one.
Um,
are you,
how could you not ask?
So martyrmade I've told you about that a bunch of times.
Like he's his scarcity of resources,
man,
that resource being time.
But nonetheless,
actually,
even though the ones I do listen to,
I don't listen to it as much cause I don't drive this much and um,
I don't do as much yard work anymore
except for that London real one.
The one that you were under the guy I've actually looked like he's on my,
he's not a podcast though.
It is really?
Yeah,
I'm subscribed to it.
Yeah.
I didn't know it was an actual podcast.
I thought it was only youtube.
I think it's like he takes the audio and put some good.
Yeah,
he's good.
He does it.
And that's the thing.
Like a lot of times people will like this.
Brian Rose London real.
Yeah,
that's a good suggestion.
He gets some cool people on this on a show and really,
really,
I mean put real simply.
It's an interview.
Even Tim Ferriss is mostly like just interview,
you know Tim Ferriss is actually absolutely an interview and then you have Joe
Rogan who's kind of like kind of an interview,
but it's more of like they're just talking about at the conferences.
So there's like all these little different subtleties that are,
that makes them different,
but
it takes a lot of skill to interview people.
Good.
Um,
and this,
uh,
the,
the London real guy goes,
yeah.
He's,
um,
he's good down to like who he chooses.
They're like pretty much across the board.
Everybody's interesting even if the subject isn't your thing.
Okay.
But the guys he chooses for those subjects are,
are pretty solid.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
Oh yeah.
And I,
I really do.
I,
I really like podcasts a lot and you can get so much information out of them and
I love the audio format.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
I just,
it's just great when you can,
when you can just sit down and listen.
And that's always what I've said for,
for,
for this podcast.
Like I want it to be something where people sit down and kind of put their
headphones on and say,
okay,
I'm getting ready to plus PR press play three,
two,
one.
Here it comes.
Yeah.
And I mean like we're doing a Q and a and obviously Q and a doesn't have that
same level of impact as if I'm going to read something either that I wrote or
something that somebody else wrote.
That's a very important subject matter that we're going to break down.
Then that's sort of,
that's,
that's what I like.
Yeah.
These,
these um,
these Q and a ones are cool because it is like,
of course we're just having a conversation about this stuff,
but it's,
there's a third person in the room as well for every question because it's their
question.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's true.
And that's one thing that's interesting is like when you're listening to,
when you're listening to any of these podcasts that I talked about,
you're basically a third person in the room sitting there listening to the
conversation.
And actually when I was on Sam Harris,
you know,
your brother drove up with me and he was in the room listening to the
conversation.
You know,
it's kind of,
it's kind of interesting,
but you know,
when you're listening to the Joe Rogan,
and actually one thing that's pretty cool is I've,
you know,
I've done an interview with Sam Harris,
had done an interview with Joe Rogan.
I've done an interview with Tim Ferriss.
Um,
I've had some good conversations with,
with um,
with Dan Carlin and I might end up being uncommon sense at some point,
but I would with the other three with Derek Cooper,
I don't know him,
but I know those guys.
I know,
I know him.
And so when I'm,
when I'm listening to a podcast,
I do feel like I'm kind of in the room with,
and sometimes I want to like answer and say something and whatever.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's the,
and I think everybody,
I think even people that never met Joe Rogan,
but they listen to all of his podcasts,
they think they're in there with them.
When I went,
I did a thing with Joe Rogan played pool with him and I went up to that studio
before.
Where'd you go up for?
With Haluk or something?
I went with,
yeah.
For a Holly.
Okay.
With them.
Yes.
For some stuff.
Um,
yeah.
So that time when it went up,
I asked him,
Hey,
do you encounter people who basically feel like they know you,
like personally?
And they'll just roll into a conversation if you like.
You've known me every single time.
Even I'm experiencing that now.
When I,
when I meet someone that goes,
hey man,
I listened to the podcast.
Hey and they're like talking to like,
well you,
y'all,
what's going on with echo in blah blah blah.
And they were like talking about me like,
like we're Bros and it's,
it's pretty cool cause in a way you are talking to them for a long time.
I know I was thinking about this.
Um,
so like hardcore history,
the,
the one podcast that is called blueprint for Armageddon,
if you haven't listened to it,
just stop and go listen to it.
It's awesome.
But that thing is,
it's five episodes,
about four hours each.
So that's 20 hours.
And when you get done with it,
man,
you,
you feel like you're pretty tight with Dan Carlin.
I mean that's 20 hours.
And then one day I was doing the math last week and we,
cause we got to 30 podcasts in there,
basically two hours each.
And I'm like,
my God,
that's 60 hours,
60 hours worth of worth of conversation with you and me.
And so absolutely people start feeling like,
you know,
hey,
oh yeah,
I know,
I know what Jocko is going to think about this or say about this.
And,
and,
and they're basically in the room here talking to us and there's that added
element there,
which is going to make that even more so with us because these are there,
these are your questions are questions and,
and I do converse with them,
you know,
on the interwebs too.
So,
so people are like,
oh,
and they'll hit me with a question and sometimes it's not enough to get on the
podcast,
but I'll just say,
yeah,
don't do that.
Right.
You know,
don't do that.
That's not smart.
Or yeah,
no,
that sounds like a good plan.
Execute,
you know,
stuff like that.
Yeah.
Just the nature of the,
but yeah,
get your podcast on and spread the word.
And,
and by the way,
thanks to thanks Tim and Joe,
uh,
those guys brought me on before I had a podcast.
Tim brought me on when the book wasn't out.
I was d basically no human being knew who I was if you weren't like in the
direct,
like if you weren't in the seal teams with me.
And,
and then Joe heard that podcast and then we connected on Twitter and he goes,
come to be on my podcast.
And I was like,
awesome.
So,
and then Sam Harris.
So anyways,
thanks to those guys for having me on and,
and spreading the word a little bit.
Yeah,
I like Sam Harris is one as well.
That's actually one of the,
one of
the few that,
that remember how we were talking before you did a podcast.
We're were like,
oh,
it'd be weird you just talking,
which actually thinking about it wouldn't be that weird.
Really.
I mean,
if you think about like even in the last podcast that we did where I just read
the book,
uh,
four hours in my life.
Right.
You didn't say much.
And you said enough to maybe get me through some,
some,
some spots where you had a question or maybe I didn't make something clear,
but,
um,
you know,
I think that's,
I think I could do it,
but,
you know,
yeah.
I don't,
I don't know why I would,
yeah.
Overall,
especially with with the Q and a whip.
And I think sometimes you'll go into things that doesn't apply to everyone's
common knowledge.
You know,
maybe only military guys will know it or only execs my notes.
So I don't,
you know,
there's less stuff.
I Dunno.
So I have the luxury of being here with me.
What do you,
what does this mean?
What does ROTC mean?
Just kidding.
I don't want ROTC me anyway.
But yeah,
Sam Harris is good though,
where he just does it Solo.
I've actually followed Sam Harris from long time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he did the one with Scott reads for the LAPD.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
And I like the Tim Ferriss one with Josh Waitzkin.
He's got a couple with him.
Josh Waitzkin really?
Uh,
his Jujitsu player.
He's a world champion chess guy.
And uh,
just just cause an interesting attitude about stuff.
Yeah.
It makes me feel like,
uh,
know there's a lot more to learn out there about things.
He wrote a book called the art of learning.
Anyways,
that's a,
that's a really good one.
Joe wrote so much of what Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan,
he's always worth less than two.
And it's weird.
Like I pretty much would Joe,
I listened to the people if I know the person that he's got on there and I don't
listen to a lot of comedians.
Right.
Cause I don't know why I like Comedians don't make me,
yeah,
that's the weird,
not weird.
That's the good thing about your Oregon because he has so many different
elements of interest is the comedians that you did to guys.
And we make a,
it's what
he does really well is he makes people talk in,
he,
you know,
I've heard him get some criticism for,
let's say he's got like a,
uh,
a religious guy on there and he doesn't believe in religion,
but he'll let that person talk about religion and won't like jump on them and
get in their face and say no.
But that's part of what makes it cool is like he's just trying to learn,
man.
He's not trying to confront people,
you know,
he's just trying to learn.
And I think that's,
I think all those people do that for the most part,
they're people that are interested in learning and they're,
they're trying to figure stuff out themselves.
And so I think it's cool that that Jill Rogan's not getting in somebody's face
about something they don't believe in.
I mean,
not that he doesn't disagree with people sometimes.
So that's,
that listened to some podcasts and,
and you know,
the other thing about this is like,
we are putting out one podcast a week and that,
I don't even know if that's sustainable.
Um,
only because of time.
I mean the amount of time that it takes to prepare a podcast.
In the beginning it was pretty easy for me cause I was doing a bunch of books
that I already read.
I already read them all.
I just crack them open.
And most of those books I read,
well read,
I mean about face already had that thing outlined and highlighted.
Um,
last hundred yards already ended.
A bunch of those beginning books were already done and it wasn't until like
until everyone on Twitter started telling me,
hey,
check out this book.
And now most of them are reading books I've never seen before and I've got to
read the book and what I do is I read it and I go through it and highlight it
and somebody asked me this question you like,
how do you prep?
So I read the book,
I go through,
I highlight the whole thing of what I think is impactful when I think is
important.
But then once you read it,
you can't just,
it does,
doesn't
it?
You just don't pick it up and read the highlighted parts in order.
Cause that doesn't always make sense.
And it also doesn't always have the,
it doesn't make people think,
it doesn't make me think about what I want to think about.
It doesn't have the impact that I want it to have.
So once I have it highlighted,
then I have to go through and plus I'll highlight,
you know,
let's say a highlight half the book.
Well then you're not going to read half the book.
So then I got to go in and figure out what really is important.
And then from there I got to organize it in the way that the timeline that I'm
actually gonna read it aloud and then make notes about whatever comments I have
about it as I'm reading it.
Because that's sort of,
that's sort of why I'm doing it.
Because I want to comment about what I'm reading because otherwise people just
go by the book and read the book yourself.
But I'm trying to give my perspective on some of it.
And so that's challenging.
And,
um,
and then the other weird thing is,
like,
I,
I've met,
I meet people all the time because I travel all the time.
I go to events and speak and companies that I'm working with.
And a lot of times the people that are there that are totally into the podcast,
if they're not even caught up there,
they're not caught up with podcast.
They're like,
hey,
I'm almost caught up.
And I'm like,
what do you mean Nicole?
I fell behind because I,
I,
I blah,
blah,
blah.
And I,
um,
I'm only on 26 right now.
And so sometimes I think,
well,
maybe people are just,
we're just turning out at such a high rate.
But then there's some people that I've talked to as,
as I think about like,
well,
maybe I need to slow down a little bit.
I've talked to some of the,
some of the people that I work with and people that listen to podcasts that are
into it.
And I say like,
you know,
we might go down to once every two weeks,
and it's like,
I just smacked him in the face.
They're like,
no,
no.
You know,
I think it'd be,
you know,
you,
but sometimes they also feel that
if I had more time that I would be able to do a better job.
Like maybe that's something I need to weigh as well.
Um,
and if you think about like hardcore history,
you call that Guy Dan Carlin is,
he just makes people,
he tortures people,
making them wait and it make you wait and wait and,
and um,
so I don't know,
maybe we,
maybe we need to go to once every two weeks.
Maybe I just need to suck it up and just keep doing.
I don't know.
Maybe I don't know yet.
But,
um,
yeah,
with the one thing that's good about all these other podcasts is that gives you
an opportunity to go listen to something else.
That's true.
Or do you go back and relisten?
Yeah,
we'll see.
I'm sure we might get some feedback on that one.
Yeah.
So people think if you out there thinks you'd be okay with us going every two
weeks or if it's gonna ruin your life.
Yeah.
Cause it probably takes 15 to 20 hours.
Now I'm a slow reader.
I'm a slow reader.
So when I'm reading a book,
I read at the same pace that I talk.
Now when I'm on the podcast,
I'm talking a little bit slower than I normally talk.
But when I'm reading,
I'm reading about the pace I'm speaking right about now.
This is just a normal and what's good about it.
And I learned this in college when I read and I'm reading at this pace,
I remember just about everything that I read.
If I read fast,
all a Tim Ferriss and speed reading,
I don't retain the same amount.
And so I read slow,
I absorb,
I'm thinking about it,
I'm making some notes.
So to get through a book takes 10 15 hours.
So then you get through with that.
Now you've got to go back through it again and decide what the actual,
the actual script timing that you're going to read it.
So now I'm like marking up the book and I'm going back and writing the page
numbers and I'm tapping it out.
That takes a few hours,
three hours.
And so by that it was all said and done.
You know,
you're talking about 20 hours,
15 to 20 hours to prep,
and
we every single day,
like today or yesterday,
I got done prepping for this podcast.
Or actually I got done prepping for the,
the,
the four hours of my life.
As soon as I got done,
I literally picked it up,
picked it up,
I stood up at my bookshelf and I started looking,
okay,
what's going on?
What's coming next?
Because I want wanna start reading it now.
Yeah.
But that's the,
the Jocko preparedness.
Yeah.
You know,
hyper preparedness,
right.
Hyper preparedness.
And also it's because when,
like I said earlier,
when somebody presses play on the podcast,
I want them to,
I want them to be getting a piece of quality material.
I'm not going to turn out something that's just,
that's just crap.
I would rather not do it at all.
I'd rather shut down and take a six month break or a lifelong break and never do
it again.
Then just start turning it out for no reason or escalated that real quick.
And I know,
you know why?
You know why I did that?
Because I have to maintain that attitude of like it like I'm not doing this,
I'm doing this because I want to do it.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I'm doing this because I want to do it and if I don't want to do it then I'm not
going to do it.
Right.
And it is,
I mean,
like I said,
I like to hit,
I like hit play on a podcast and be like,
okay,
this is it.
Just like sitting down to listen to great music or anything like that that the
podcast for me is like that.
It's like reading a great book.
It's like watching a great movie.
It's sitting down pressing play and going,
okay,
this is going to have impact on me.
And so I want to turn something out like that.
I don't want to turn out to second rate stuff.
I want to turn out something legit.
And if I,
if I failed to do that,
then I'm not going to do it.
At least now I'm seeing if I was failed to do it,
but I was trying my hardest.
Okay.
I might continue cause I'm just trying to make them.
But if I was failing to do it cause I wasn't putting the effort into it,
then I'm not going to do it.
Cause that's,
I think,
I think that my personal expectations and the expectations that people have when
they press play,
they want to get something good.
They want to get some quality,
they want to learn something,
they want to,
they want to enter into the game.
Whereas if they start pressing play and they hear garbage,
man,
I don't want them to hear that.
And I don't want to be that.
That's not my gig.
My gig is going hard,
putting out hard and putting out something that,
that people want to listen to because it helps them not doing it just to do it.
That's not my thing.
Yeah.
And if you start slipping in that regard,
right,
you can smell it from a mile away,
man.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what,
the one thing I have realized when I first started,
I thought,
oh,
well,
I don't know.
You know,
there's only so many books you know,
that I could actually do cause I'm,
I'm thinking books that had impact on me.
Real legit impact.
There wasn't some huge list,
right?
But as soon as I started going down the path,
now I realize that there's literally I could,
I could,
I'm not going to be able to do in my lifetime all the books I want to do.
You know what I mean?
Not just not going to happen in enlisting other people to make suggestions,
which people are enlisted to.
Every trooper out there sending me two or three books and saying,
hey,
check this out.
My Amazon Bill.
Click through to Jocko podcasts,
click through to Amazon.
We got it going on because after that monies from me,
because I'm ordering books all the time,
when somebody says,
Hey,
check this book out.
I don't really have time to play around.
Do you know what I do?
I just order it.
I just click through ordered on Amazon.
Well I need,
I'm literally literally getting a new bookshelf in my house because I've got so
many books piling up and yeah,
that to me,
well what's good about it?
I love this guy.
And this is another thing,
and I told you this early on because early on you said,
hey,
you know,
it was like three weeks into it,
you're like,
hey,
I don't know if we were able to keep up this pace.
And I said,
you know what?
I like this grind.
I want to be a maxed out,
I want to have the pedal down.
And you know what?
I want to be going hard.
And I think the people that listened to the podcast are people that are going
hard in their perspective lives.
They're going there,
they're working hard,
they're making things happen,
they're being aggressive.
And that's what I'm doing here.
That's what we're doing here.
And so I think that's why it resonates with some people.
And there's some people that are listening to this that know that they kind of
step it up a little,
you know?
And that also is a good thing.
Yeah.
I don't think there's too many people that are like,
Jocko get your,
get your,
get it together.
You need to get your game on.
They know I'm bringing my a game,
right.
I,
I'm bringing my a game and people know that but the day that I can't bring my a
game then a couple of things,
maybe it's I'm okay,
you know what,
I need more time cause I don't want to turn out crap or I don't do it anymore or
we do it whenever.
But
I like being driven.
I like a deadline.
I learned a lot from the podcast from,
from getting ready for it.
Cause you gotta remember I read a book so you got a little bit by listening to
an hour of me talking about a book,
I read a book,
I absorbed it,
I highlighted it,
I outlined it,
I researched it,
I looked up and I look up.
Oh that general,
he sounds like an interesting,
I don't,
we just do a real quick fact check to see if there's anything in the behind the
scenes I needed to tell about him.
Oh,
you don't want,
there's a poem that's related to this.
I'm taking out poems that I didn't know,
didn't understand in reviewing them.
So all these little things that you don't want and who knows?
I mean,
does this,
should this be the full time job?
I've,
I don't know you,
you know,
and by the way,
the whole time that I'm doing this,
I got a business,
you know,
with life that were traveling and working with companies.
I got other books in the hopper that I'm writing currently and I have to spend
time doing that,
which I'm super pumped about those as well.
But like those,
that takes time.
So yeah.
Dang.
But,
but again,
you know what,
bring it on.
Bring it on,
You mean jump in there?
I'm going to answer your Twitter questions.
I'm going to deliver some podcasts yet.
Baja.
I can make it happen.
Some people choose to get after it and red line and we encourage that red line.
That's what I'm talking about in a red line.
This bad boy.
Speaking of red lining.
Next question,
please discuss how discipline equals freedom can and should apply to one's
financial life.
Thanks from all the strippers,
uh,
d obviously if you want to be financially free,
you got to have financial discipline.
That's just the way it is.
So here's,
it's just simple,
not easy.
Save your money.
Boom.
That's number one.
Don't buy an X.
Here's one.
Don't buy an expensive car
until you own a piece of property.
That's just a basic rule.
Yup.
If you're driving a Mercedes
s class from 2015 is that a good one to ask?
It's a very good one.
Yeah,
it's a very good one,
but it's also $120,000.
But if you're living,
if you're renting the wrong move,
sell that thing and buy a piece of property.
A car is a depreciating of properties or properties and appreciating asset to
try and put your money into your appreciating assets.
Spend less than you earn.
Boom.
Stay off the credit cards.
Invest your money in something.
I like to invest money in me
in things that I'm going to do.
That's what I want to do.
I want to invest money in things that I know and understand and what better do I
know and understand that then things that I'm doing,
people that I know or things that I'm involved with.
So
that's what you gotta do.
You want us,
you want to get your money taking care of,
you want to,
you want to have financial freedom,
you've got to just have the financial discipline that that's all there is to it
and work hard,
you know,
or card make things happen.
But your,
your major gains,
you know,
most people don't become rich by their salary,
right.
They become baby,
they,
they earn their wealth,
they gained their wealth through bigger things like buying properties.
You know,
we got a Jiu Jitsu player at the,
at the academy,
a girl and you know,
a year ago she was kind of talking to me about,
oh well you know,
you know,
she just got married and Blah Blah Blah.
And we started talking.
I said,
you,
you know,
with,
I'll think about moving.
I got this condo and I was like,
we started talking about buying properties and boom,
she disclosed on a like a four four unit property in San Diego.
And the day she got the keys,
she was making $400 a month.
She went from paying $1,900 a month in mortgage.
The day she made,
she got the keys.
All of a sudden that she rented that place out,
she's got three units she's living in with crappiest unit and she's got those
things rented out and now she's making $400 a month.
So that's a,
that's a Delta of what,
$2,300 a month in the black.
That's impressive.
And it took her a year to get done,
but she did it.
And now I said,
she's like,
I'm so happy.
I'm like,
that's cool.
Start saving.
Start saving for your next property.
I'm like,
the market's going to take a downturn.
You gotta be ready if it doesn't,
if it does,
but you gotta be ready to make that next move.
So start saving your money.
Start paying that thing down.
Start saving your money.
Started saving the next down payment.
That's where you're a wealth gets established as an easy,
long term strategic moves that you make.
And you know,
I'm no financial expert,
but you don't have to be a financial expert to know,
to save your money,
to spend less than you earn.
Um,
and,
and property to me is a good thing to invest in.
It does go up and down,
you know,
and there's a lot of people that got crushed in the,
in the market downturn in 2007 in 2008 and I was in the military,
so I was buying houses and I didn't even know that the market downturn,
it didn't matter to me cause I had had a steady job and I just bought those
properties just to,
just to have properties.
I wasn't buying them to flip them and sell them and all that.
No,
I was just like,
okay,
in some,
some time in the future,
someone's going to be paying me rent and it's gonna go in my pocket.
And that sounds like a good to me cause they're not making any more real estate
by the beach.
Right.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
I'm not a financial genius.
Talk to somebody that is smart.
Talk to somebody that understands finances,
but save your money,
spend less than you earn.
Don't be renting if you don't be renting a place,
if you're buying a outline and Mercedes s class or a seven series or a range
rover by low piece of property,
but I little thing.
Yup.
Bye.
Little thing.
Don't just go by that little something.
Get in there,
get it started.
Yeah man,
I like this.
Invest in yourself.
Yeah,
because and invest in yourself.
That's a such a broad term.
And actually it's kind of started to become like a little like cliche catch,
freeze yourself.
But if you really think about that,
you yeah.
You invest in yourself,
you don't go by,
you know,
I used to work in the nightclub industry,
right?
So I'm,
and I'm now,
I'm looking with my mindset now,
looking back at the people I used to deal with.
I used to be,
see people come in there every weekend and spend a lot of money.
I don't know,
maybe some of them are already are rich or,
but I know that if that's what you're spending your money on,
you're going down and essentially just buying drinks,
buying nightclubs,
there's no essential oil.
That's what you're doing.
You're throwing,
if thinking back like thinking back five years ago,
you spent all your money,
not all your money,
but you spend a bunch of money on drinks and what you have literally nothing to
show for it.
And in most cases those it's gonna mess you up in one way.
You going to do something you regret or whatever potentially.
So think of that same five years and be like,
Dang,
what if I started these two things that in my prediction is going to help me in
five years?
And let's say you did that five years ago and you did it.
I don't know,
you even practice it like an hour a day,
whatever it is.
Even just improving your knowledge on the economy or something,
I dunno.
Anything,
anything that improves your knowledge.
Five years later you could,
you could be essentially an expert at it.
So now just consider it.
Now,
what is it that you should have gotten into?
Because you probably have a handful of interests that are pretty cool to you.
Even if it's like playing guitar,
I don't know,
whatever,
but if you can make it something that you can anticipate in five years,
it's going to be your,
if you're talking about financial stuff,
it's going to help you make money.
It didn't do that.
Don't,
and I harp on reality TV a lot,
but I think it kind of deserves it because you don't learn much reality TV yet.
You lost like that hour and if you spent that hour and really you could kind of
keep watching reality if you want,
but just spend that one hour doing something that you anticipate if you're
really good at it would help you financially do that thing for one hour and then
one day's going to come and you're to think back,
oh
look,
just the same way.
I'm thinking back five years ago,
I mean in my case is more than five years ago,
but just the same way.
I'm thinking back of those people at the nightclub industry.
Same Way.
I'm thinking back about that.
You're going to be thinking back at yourself and you'd be like,
Dang,
I'm so happy I got into that,
you know?
Yeah.
And there's all kinds of things you could have done.
I mean,
I've looked at the money I wasted over the years in the bars.
It's ridiculous.
You know,
being a young seal out,
getting after it with the boys Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and the Sunday.
That's how we used to roll.
Yeah.
That's how we used to roll and it was just,
hey,
we'd show up.
I'm the richest guy in the world.
I have all the money that I ever need and I can buy whatever I want.
That's what every night was like.
So not wise.
Don't do that.
Yeah.
And I'll even
go out,
have some fun.
It's cool.
You can still do it.
I'm just saying,
think of that.
Think of what you're doing right now and your cause for these people and for
these people I was talking about back when he was working the nightclub
industry,
they are really,
technically,
they are committed to spending their money committed to it.
Yeah.
If you're doing something every single week for years,
you're committed to it.
So just take one of those hours or take maybe 10% of that money that you're
spending,
25% all of it,
whatever,
and put it in something that you anticipate.
And the other thing is,
I mean,
invest in yourself as like actually build something.
Actually built a little company,
you know,
make something.
That's what that,
that's what I was meant.
You've got another perspective which is also very viable and makes just as much
sense.
I was literally talking about,
you know,
from your perspective,
oh you like guitars,
cool.
Figuring out how to make a cool guitar.
Stand at your house,
you know,
and then see if he can get that thing produced and then,
oh,
it's really good.
Maybe we start running production.
Let's do that.
That is internally,
not only,
not only will you possibly end up with some kind of a product that sells,
but you'll have grown something.
You've had fun,
you created something for the world,
you've learned the lessons that you learned about building,
getting,
get him African.
That's how it's all going to be worthwhile as well.
So there's no this,
this,
I'm not saying this,
um,
with regards to that,
you're going to come up with this product and you're going to get rich.
It's not going to happen.
But can you use that to build knowledge,
can use that to get gain experience that will then compound with other things in
your life and eventually make you financially free because you had that
discipline?
Absolutely.
Yes.
Yup.
Next question.
Does micromanaging ever work?
Well,
yes.
And,
and more.
Does it work?
Yes.
Sometimes it works.
And more importantly,
sometimes you have to micromanage.
Um,
so you get somebody that isn't good at their job,
doesn't do a good job,
doesn't show up,
doesn't run things right.
Of course,
you know how you fix them.
You got to get in there to micromanage.
Well,
first of all,
you can't do mission failure.
So you gotta get in there to micromanage.
Once you're done micromanaging or,
or once you've got them up to speed,
then you can stop micromanaging.
This is,
this is totally good to go.
And even if you asked life or you know,
the other platoon commanders that worked for me or assistant between commanders
at work for me,
if when we say when they got to know me,
when they met me,
I was Mike Rowe manage master cause I'm in their grill,
hey this,
you got to do this.
No,
come over here a little bit.
No and wouldn't give any slack.
But then as soon as I see that they get it,
of course then it's like,
okay,
you got this,
you got this and I'm going to,
I'm going to macro manage and barely manage and let them run with it.
And so that's,
that's absolutely micromanagement is sometimes it's a necessity.
And by the way,
if you're getting micromanaged,
that's a little bit of a red flag.
I'm sure you might have somebody that's a control freak that is a compulsive
micromanager and that sucks.
But you also might have somebody that doesn't trust you yet.
And so how do you build up their trust?
Is it by hiding from them?
No,
it's by being open and being like,
hey boss,
here's what I'm gonna do.
You actually send them more information than they could even want.
You show them how responsible you are.
You show them what a handle you have on the situation and that's how you can
help overcome the micro manager.
But if someone's not doing what they're supposed to do or they're failing or
they're,
they're letting you down,
then yeah,
you've got to get in their grill and micromanage them.
The other time that sort of said this is when you're mentoring someone,
that can also be viewed as micromanagement because now I'm sitting side by side
and my breathing down your neck a little bit and that might be viewed as
micromanagement.
But again,
sometimes it's necessary.
If you don't know the ropes yet,
I got to show you the ropes.
That means I've got to sit by you and make sure you know it.
Um,
teaching.
So if you're teaching somebody something in a work environment,
that can also be viewed as micromanagement,
it actually is because you're saying,
hey,
put this over here,
put that over here,
wait back off,
let me do this.
No,
no,
you don't know how to do it.
So I got to show you how to do,
I'm teaching you how to do it.
So there's that and,
and then that's teaching and then sometimes you've got to show people how to do
it.
And I told that long story in here one time where I just said,
hey,
you sit and watch how I'm going to run this squad.
And I ran the squad and got fired up and told people where to go and move down
the line.
And the platoon commander looked at me and said,
okay,
I can do that.
And as soon as you saw at one time he got it.
So that's sometimes micromanagement is okay.
The thing is you don't want to get stuck in the Rut of micromanagement.
So if I mentor you,
if I teach you,
if I instruct you,
if I showed you the way,
it doesn't mean stay there and keep micromanaging cause you're not doing your
job.
You shouldn't have the capability or the capacity to micromanagement to
micromanage everybody that works for you.
If you have that ability,
you're not doing your job,
you're not looking up the chain of command,
you're not looking out your troopers,
your subordinate leadership should be stepping up and leading and you should
expect that of them.
And if you have to micro management,
it should be a chore that you don't like doing.
And when you get in there and you micromanage for a certain amount of time,
then you say,
okay,
you got this.
You know,
um,
I'm stepping back.
And then you've got to step back because no one likes to be micromanaged.
So once you get people up to speed,
step back,
let them run,
let your leaders lead.
Yeah.
Sometimes those people who like to micromanage or they feel compelled to,
they can fall in that trap where,
where let's say they do need to micromanage and they'll get that payoff of,
Oh yeah,
I see this guy kind of getting it.
But instead of understanding the full scope of things where,
oh,
he's getting it now,
I need to,
I don't need to manage as much.
There'll be like,
they'll still start chasing that payoff of them getting it with their little
micromanagement,
you know,
so they'll like constantly need that pay off some people now that you mentioned,
some people micromanage because their ego that they want to,
they want to exercise,
they want to do two things,
exercise their power over the person or,
or show off their knowledge to the person.
Yeah,
so those two are just such a pain.
There's such a pain,
but you know what?
What do you do?
Okay,
cool.
I'm going to work harder.
I'm going to be ahead of you.
I'm going to get better at this and we're going to move on.
Yeah.
That showing off knowledge thing that,
that,
that it's in a micromanagement situation it seems like,
okay.
It's obviously you shouldn't do that and you could probably see it from a mile
away,
but just in everyday life,
that's a compelling thing to want to show people.
You ever,
you ever hear someone telling you something that you already know and you just
want to tell them?
Probably.
I already know.
I know.
You know,
like you don't have to explain it to me when really when you really kind of
search your own feelings,
it's not that they're wasting your time,
it's kind of that you just want to let them know that I have that knowledge,
don't worry about it.
You know what I mean?
I see that all the time.
I feel that all the time she's got to grin and bear it.
But I think that's,
that's a real compelling like desire,
you know,
to to show,
hey,
I already know that.
Or look how much I know.
You know?
Yeah.
People definitely like that.
It's,
it makes them feel good and look at what,
I know,
you know,
last question
Jocko.
Focus in a battle is easy.
How do you keep focus in a long war
I.
E.
Longterm goals
that that Greg can definitely be true.
It can be pretty easy to focus on the battle that's right in front of your face.
And when you're doing that,
sometimes you can lose track of the,
the long term goal.
But I want to have that,
that long term goal.
So embedded in my mind that I'll never lose sight of it ever.
And those little tasks and projects and short term goals that you tackle,
they need to lead toward that strategic victory,
winning the long war
and we get very caught up in instant gratification.
We want results now we want the shortcut to the winner's podium
and sometimes you know,
when we don't get that short term glory that we want,
we lose track of those long term goals and you,
you look up and in six weeks or in six months or in six years and you've made no
progress,
no,
you never moved.
You might even be further from your goal then you were
why?
Why did you let that happen?
It's because you lost sight of that longterm goal
and at some point after you lose sight of that goal and years have gone by,
you'd think to yourself,
maybe I can't,
okay,
maybe I can't do it.
And so you give up and you let it feed
and you settle.
You settle for mediocrity,
you settle for average,
you settle for
oh well,
but no,
no,
don't do that.
Embed that long term goal in your mind,
burn it into your soul,
think about it and write about it and talk about it and hang it up on your wall.
But most important,
do something about it.
Do something about it.
Every day,
every day.
Do something that moves you toward that goal that keeps the goal alive and
insight and in focus.
However,
however small or insignificant that step might seem,
take it.
Do it to that little piece,
make it happen,
because that goal isn't going to achieve itself.
Eats all on
you.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight,
which means
it's time to wrap it up.
Echo,
what else do we have?
We have the four important fact that if you're into supplements,
these are the supplements that we,
I'm gonna speak for you for a second.
Will you recommend it's on it?
Supplements,
specifically Krill oil for your joints and shroom tech for what does it do it
metcon performance it,
it in a nutshell kind of boiled down.
It's it,
it helps you utilize oxygen consumption,
which is a good thing.
Yes.
Performance side,
very much so.
And yes,
it does work.
Ask anyone who's ever taken it and then what were your bar?
That's a good one.
Yeah,
and by the way,
if you,
if you do get these items that are going to help you,
you'll also be helping us here on the podcast.
Yup.
And you'll get helped discount wise if you go on.com/jocko 10% off.
Nice.
You didn't already know.
Anyway,
there's a lot of good stuff on there.
Supplements you can read about them.
If you read about the quality,
it's some gear equipment on there as well.
Yeah,
get yourself some Zombie bells,
[inaudible] dot com slash Jocko 10% off all supplements
or before you do Amazon shopping.
If you shop at Amazon,
which I think we all do before that,
before you go to amazon.com go to Jocko podcast.com and then click on the Amazon
links like a little affiliate thing.
Beautiful on that.
You can support Jocko podcasts.
That's a beautiful shopping,
easy,
easy to really easy.
Trust me,
I've done it before.
And then,
um,
Jocko,
store.com.
That's where if you,
if you like sh you know,
shirts and apparel in regards to this podcast is good.
Some good ones I think speaking of which,
if you didn't already know,
we have the trooper one just kind of new.
It's the new stuff.
If you're on youtube anyway.
Yep.
That's just like the Jocko podcast tee shirt.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's no doubt what that t shirt is.
Yeah.
Cause Jocko podcast.
Yeah it does.
Yep.
It's true.
And you know there's,
I put layers,
I try to put these different layers on the apparels,
not just Ooh,
jacket pocket.
So there's a little some more to it.
Right,
right.
So then I'm not going to say what it is for this one,
but there's another layer to it.
So if you want,
yeah,
Jocko,
store.com if you want to look at it and just evaluate it,
you like it,
go ahead and get it.
That's a good way to support the podcast.
Yes,
very much so.
Or if you like to discipline equals freedom.
That one,
which we talked about today.
What is the,
what is sort of the,
the most popular of the tee shirts?
It goes in waves.
So I'd say generally speaking,
discipline equals freedom because the is the solid seller.
Yeah.
And that makes sense.
Because again,
like that's their mantra.
Yeah.
And,
and that's not,
it seems like,
oh,
it's kind of intriguing as of a thing like discipline equals freedom is kind of
counterintuitive,
but when you really think about it,
I dunno,
it's kind of impactful.
I think it's a good thing to live by anyway.
I agree with you nonetheless.
So maybe that's why,
I dunno.
And then I'm the good one is kind of cool.
I think that was more festive,
you know?
But yeah,
there's a few on there,
some stickers and some mugs as well if,
um,
but yeah,
if you go on there,
Jocko,
store.com like I said,
um,
and you know,
whichever one you like,
get down.
Yeah.
Go with it.
Appreciate the support.
Yup.
Well,
you can also support the podcast by,
by hitting us up on the interwebs.
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
That's on Twitter,
on the Facebooky and even on Instagram.
I primarily respond on the Twitter if you have a question,
but I do look at the other ones as well.
Uh,
so thanks for supporting that way.
Thanks for downloading.
Thanks for subscribing.
Thanks for spreading the word,
but most of all,
thanks for staying focused on those long term goals that you have,
those dreams that you got,
and for keeping those in mind as you go out there
and get after it.
And so until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.